[音楽]
[拍手]
私は
地域で子どもの育ちの環境を作る活動
取り組んでいます
私が日々地域の中で活動している中で
大切だと感じている
分かち合いについてですね少し今日はお話しさせていただければなと思っております
早速ですが
この一点9この数字は何でしょうか
いま世界でば
2030年までに
あらゆる貧困をなくすという目標を立てています
2015年
国際連合の総会で合意されたグローバル目標
その最初の目標に品行なくすとあります
1.9は
世界銀行が
2015年に定めた貧困のラインです
1日
$1.99以下で生活している人たちが世界7億人ほどいると悲惨されています
日本円で200円
皆さん生活できますかね
もう今日のいうもの買った方は残りの釣りで生活してみてください
実際には難しいことはよくわかると思います
この水準でいうと日本には貧困がないんではないか
そう考える人の方が多いのかもしれません
しかし今日本では
1/66人に1人が貧困
また子どもの貧困という状態にあると言われています
先ほどの数字からすると
本当にあるのかと感じるかもしれません
でも良く考えいただけると日本は物価も高いですし
当たり前のような生活をしようとすると実際にはたくさんのお金がかかります
所得で考えると日本の
貧困の基準になっているのは親と子2人の家庭だとだいたい月15万円ぐらいです
この15万円なくから家賃とか
水光熱費とか教育費とか最低限必要なお金と今の日本で
子供が当たり前に享受するもの例えば携帯電話だったり
宿だ習い事だ部活動だ
また家族旅行だったりとか
そういったものにお金はかかります
贅沢しなければ
いいんじゃないかそういう方もおられるかもしれませんが
実際にこのお金で
一人暮らしだったらなんとかなりますが家族を養いながら生活をしていこうと思うと
なかなか難しいです
実際に貯金ができな米は進学ということも難しいかも知れませ
ぜひ皆さんこの金額で自分が生活できるか考えてみてください
実際には
最低限必要なお金だけではなくてですね友達付き合いとか関係を維持していく
そんなことにも実はお金がかかります
同じことをする
まあ同調圧力みたいなものを感じている子供たちもたくさんいます
同じことが出来なければいじめられたり
孤立したり
そうならないために大丈夫だと当たり前にできるとね
装って過ごしている子供たちもたくさんいます
実際にはできないことが増えていきますので
一つ一つ諦めを積み上げていくことになります
そして
そのできないことを大人に相談してみても
答えてもらえない
そうすると今度は大人に相談することも諦めます
最後は大人に期待することや大人そのものへの諦め
というものを積み上げることになっていきます
これが
誰が見ても絶対的な貧困というような状態ではなくて各区にでそれぞれに社会生活を
行う上での総体的な貧困と言います
もちろんお金がなくても
何とかなった人たちはたくさんいます皆さんが諦めているわけではありません
その点では貧困や
貧乏というものは意味が違うと思ってください
日常生活
やることはたくさんいますそして将来に向けても取り組むべきことがたくさんあります
実際にはそういったものの中から
やれることをやれないことというものがあるわけですが
子供の時は解決できなくても大丈夫だったりお金をかけなくても解決できることも
たくさんありますが
実際その差はごくわずかです
そんなちーさんさができることが
日常生活生活全般に生じてきます
本当に小さなさでいうならば例えば皆さんお風呂入りますよね
幌入った時にどうですかシャンプーとかボディーソープなかったらどうですか
お風呂に入っているという行為はしていますが実際には赤が取れていなかったりフケが
方にたまっていたり
そんな子どもたちを見た大人がお風呂に入っているって尋ねても
はいて元気を答えてくれます
小さなさ
もしくはこれまでそういったものを確かめようとしたことが理由ではなかなか気付け
ない
そんなちーさんさまたは
子どもたち自身が同じことができているように装っていっ
恥ずかしいから見栄を張ったりしていく
そうやって乗り越えている子供達がいますが一つ一つの混乱困りごと小さな差でしか
ないですので子ども自身も
気づいていないし大人もそのさに気付けていません
実際大人たちは同じことができているから大丈夫と思い込みます
結果子どもたちのこんなの前を素通りし
見逃します
お店たちは
実際に
同じことをできている子供達に安心をしていますが大切なのは子供たちが皆と同じよう
に装うこと
を求めるのではなくて子供たちが他の子たちと同じことをしたいと思ったときにそれが
できるようにその壁となっている
障壁を解決していけるような環境
分かち合ったり問題解決手段届けるということしなければいけないわけですが
晏菜たちは気づいていないのでそこにて
を差し伸べようとはしていません
結果
だんだん困りごとが増えて複雑化していきます
だんだん解決もできなくなっていきますなぜならば解決手段を獲得する経験が不足して
いくからです
その上で小さな困りごとや混乱が増えていき
もともと抱えていた生活の悩み
本欄を
抱えながら毎日それ4つ蓄積していきます
いずれ限界に達します
そういったものがたくさん混ざり合って今の子供たちの本欄を生み出しています
だから本人たちなんで困ってるのって聞いてもわからないんですよね
わからないからどう解決していいかもわからないし
何に取り組んでいいかもわからねぇ
わからなければ努力することすらできなくなります
そして何より今を生きることに必死になっています
私は京都の山科というところで生まれ育ち
そしてその地元でこの山科醍醐こどものひろばっていう団体を運営しています
こどもの広場には
0歳から18歳までの子どもたち
そしてはかもね大人たちがボランティアとして関わってくれています
37年
目に入りました
世代を超えて
子どもたちが参加してくれます
かつて子どもだった人も親になって子供を連れて行きます
そういった子どもたちに
子供活動
届け続けるということをしているわけですが
実際にその活動が地域の子どもたちの状況に応じて
活動を作っていくってことをしています
子どもの貧困は2008年ごろから日本で騒がれるようになりましたが
実際にその前から子どもたちの困りごとに答えるというような形で活動をつくってきて
います
実際行っている活動は
当たり前を埋め直す
そういった活動です
自分が生まれた街のこどもたちが
幸せに笑顔で
暮らしてほしいと単純に思います
実際に活動の様子は
家庭のように少人数子供大人が何人かだけで活動をしています
写真のようにご飯を食べたり勉強したりお風呂に入ったり
若ちゃうものは
経験や時間や場所関係などさまざまです
その他にも
子どもたちと直接出会い対話をする機会を設けたり子どもたちの困りごとに気づける人
を増やすそういった活動にも取り組んでいます
しかしまだまだ子供たちの困りごとに気づける大人ば少数です
ぜひみなさん子どもに関わっていただき
子どもの心の叫び耳を傾けてください
家庭の経済的な困難や親子関係のこんな
先ほどお話したような諦めとかごまかし
みたいなものがたくさん困難としてミックスされたものが子どもの貧困です
実際にお金のことだけであるならば
富の再分配をすればいいことですから国や行政に頑張っていただく
これがまず第一になります
しかし子供たちはすでに
心に穴を抱えてしまっていますこれは政策だけでは帰れません
そこで大事なのは困難を解消していくための軸になります
実際には子どもたちは今もすでに困っています
そしてその状態で長く放置されてきました
だから子供たちに大切なことは新しく
子どもたち自身が生きる姿を形作っていく
ことが大事になりますそのためには多くの方々から
様々な生き方に触れさせてもらったり他の生き方があるんだということを知って知らせ
てもらうようなそういった場面が必要になってきます
そこで皆さん方には是非ね人生
で今まで積み上げてきたものを分かちちゃうそういった取り組みをしていただきたいな
と思っています
放置されてきた時間の何倍も新しい生き方を構築するには時間がかかるかもしれません
ぜひ皆さんに生き方や時間や関係や夢やお金といった皆さんが人生で作ってきた有形
無形の財産
これを分かち合って頂けると嬉しいなと思っ
ています
そのためにはまず子どもたちと出会ってください
関わってみてくださいそして子どもと大人と一緒に子どもたちが安心できる環境
楽しめる場を共に体験し分かち合ってみてください
その中できっと子どもたちの困りごとに気づくことができると思います
一方で現場では
困った子は困っている子という言葉があります
困難を抱えていると困りごと上手く表現ができずにコミュニケーションを取れなかっ
たり
集団に馴染めなかったり大声出したり暴言吐いたり暴力振るったり
様々な形で皆さんから見たら困った子の姿を見せてくれます
しかしそれは助けてのサインかもしれません
そのためにまずどんな形であれサインが出てくるそれを見逃さないということがまず第
一になります
その1個目見逃さない気づきの上ですね
2本目その際について考えてみてください
そして考えて子供たちの困りごとの背景に思い馳せそれを周りの人達ぜひ気づいて
ください
まず気づく人が増えるこれが子どもの貧困を解消していくための第一歩になります
子どもの貧困は
地域の未来の姿です
ぜひ
今の日ものを1本飲むときにですね少しでも世界の貧困
日本の貧困そして子供の変更について少し思いを馳せて頂けると嬉しいなと思います
子どもたちに皆さんは何を分かち合えるのか
ぜひ考えてみてください
子どもたちに諦めではなく
将来に届ける希望を共に作っていければなと思っています
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]